you guys seem like a great crab wouldn't
you agree Andi oh I sure do I want to
say a special welcome to our Premium
ticket golden ticket and platinum ticket
holders okay
I'm sorry what are you talking about
Andi everyone gets the same ticket to
the show don't they yeah maybe in
communist Russia this year there's four
ticket levels to our Comic Con shows
check it out if you're a standard ticket
holder you get free admission to the
hottest show at Comic Con plus your very
own seat inside and all the air you can
breathe level up to a premium ticket and
you get front of the line access to all
Spreckels theater bathrooms including
toilet eviction privileges with the gold
ticket you get a private meet and greet
with Conan prop masterbuilt Oh diehard
Conan fans can treat themselves to a
Platinum ticket you get a first-class
trip to Brazil $25,000 worth of facial
surgery body sculpting hair implants and
pigment reductions to make you look
exactly like Conan O'Brien or me Andy
Richter
anything none of that none of that is
true nobody's gonna spend 25,000 to get
surgery to look like us
oh yeah well tell that to Tom and linda
mcfarlane Columbus Ohio here's what they
look like last week and here they are
tonight
I'm just curious I'm just curious how do
you how do you feel I've made a horrible
mistake tamil and everybody thank you I
[Music]
think she's very attractive
[Applause]
you